good morning John I didn't see you on
Tuesday I mean I know we said we were
gonna take vacation days but now one
actually happened and I'm just adjusting
I'm just dealing with that I mean
vacations a bit of a stretchy word in
this situation I think that's true of a
lot of vacations these days we go on
vacation by which we mean we're not
doing our normal work we're doing some
kind of abnormal work whether that's
going to a wedding with 500 people you
don't know at all like taking a vacation
day so you can buy a car because it
takes a full freaking day to buy a car
anyway the point is John you are in
Sierra Leone with Partners in Health
looking at how we us as individuals and
we this whole community might be able to
help make life easier there particularly
for pregnant people but also babies who
are great unless they decided that it
was time to scream every night starting
at 2:30 in the morning for no reason
they're still great I'm sorry I'm sorry
it's a lot right now
and it turns out not great internet
where you were at and also not a lot of
free time to make a video so I'm looking
forward to hearing more about what
happened you know while you were in
Sierra Leone and I was having four
different April Fool's jokes sorry yeah
dftba brewery not a real thing not a
real never gonna be a real thing but the
merch is real emerge is always real and
also all of John and i's after-tax dftba
profits going to be going to charity
lovely to help do a project with
partners in health so if you want that
good old dftba brewing merch it's
available only until today baby we'll
make it through the weekend also scishow
pee is not a real thing though it is a
real You Tube channel and if it does get
a hundred thousand subscribers we will
get a silver play button from YouTube
that says scishow pee on it so do with
that information what you wish there a
link in the description probably I
couldn't tell you for sure there might
be one right here just go do it we're
never gonna make another video on that
channel so what do you have to lose John
am i 38 years old or do i luvs means
yeah both this is my friend Valerie's
draw a horse scene they had people draw
a picture and send in one picture of one
horse I don't know what's happening here
occasionally you get a little blurb from
the person about their horse
I have personally picked a favorite
horse you can get this I'll put a link
to their Etsy in the description it's
this one I
love how muscley and bony it is it's
like a centaur but only the torso is of
a man if that was your horse great work
I want to do a similar thing I saw a
reddit thread that was extremely
intriguing to me that asks people to
describe the bar that they picture when
they hear a like a man walked into a bar
joke I never thought about this before
but I have a bar I have a specific bar
that I've never been to that is a very
weird layout and I want people to draw
me their bars that a man walked into and
maybe I'll just make a video about it
maybe I'll make a zine about it and the
meantime I want you to draw me a bar and
I want you to put it into the internet
somehow and send it to me at Hank and
John at gmail.com with my bar in the
subject line that's all you have to do
and then I have to figure out what to do
with those don't worry I'm fine I got
lots of free time I don't have to write
oh look oh gosh sequels are wild well
recently in the book I made up a person
and then I was like this doesn't work
and then I'm got rid of them and they
don't exist anymore it's my job I you
decide whether you exist there are too
many milks my son is two and a half
years old and he asks for oat milk and
his tea what have I done
send me your bars and they may be dftba
brewery someday but they won't but the
merch is real youtube.com/scishow pee
John I'll see you on Tuesday for real
this time
apparently I'm still capable of making
an entirely unscripted video I guess
what do you think actually in the
comments let me know what your favorite
recent YouTube discovery was the funk
Lynde is doing a series on Jim Henson
and I'm super psyched about it